my name is Malik and every wall it's
John wait here
hi my name's Kim joy and I am from the
great British Baker today I'm going to
answer questions and tell you a little
bit more about Baker
[Music]
don't start barking dog how hard is
attempt yeah so very hard Dante's
Inferno hot
I'm a cop wonderful it reached 34
degrees for chocolate week and you know
that chocolate melts at 20 degrees so
yes it gets really hot I was constantly
do you shoot on weekends only for the
most part we shot only on weekends I
think oh well two days where we did a
Friday how did you balance the show with
your everyday life did you still have to
go to work at the time I was also
project managing software so I was
consulting and I still had my clients
that was in Birmingham which is two
hours away from London which is where I
live yes we have to go to work still I
was a lawsuit to the time so I would
have an exam on Friday go down to
Bristol in the UK where was filmed to
film the bake-off on something Sunday
and then come back on Sunday night to
have a law degree exam
so I actually quit my job so that I
could focus a pletely on vapor an
apartment theory supported me through
that Oh Florence I don't know how I
would have done it
do you like them the hosts come by and
chat with you as you're baking yeah I
liked it because you know what I'm
baking I'm just in my own world and I
don't feel like it's real I think I love
baking with people around so I didn't
have in mind you know them coming and I
think it just less lonely no it was very
helpful actually to have melon soup we
have gone through the time and they were
very lovely they were a great emotional
support how much the information do they
give you beforehand for the signature
pink or the showstopper challenge I
think you get a full brief of maybe two
sides of a4 paper and then you have
about two or three weeks of practice so
you do get a good brief we got pretty
much all the information for those
because they're not like the technicals
where you're not meant to know how much
information do you actually get for the
technical challenges we get no
information now that nothing I think you
make the jump make the Pentax is here
thank you failure not more information
as the week's go on yeah
[Music]
I'll see youse did you take at home
practice bakes someone makes sure that
things like choux pastry like for
example I know that takes half an hour
and I practice that through and then I
practice the next element select the
decorating and I add it all together so
I know exactly how long something takes
I was like that maryberry I was that
serious I was like gasps kitchen don't
speak to me but I bought the windows put
newspaper on the windows so people
couldn't see did you have to spend your
own money on that home practice takes I
did well I didn't Isis than my
boyfriend's money because I was an
impoverished destitute student at the
time but I think we got about 100 quid
from the production company to practice
and I made a pecan pie which cost 25
quid every time we get some money too
and spent for our ingredients and how
does wardrobe what do you choose your
own outfit yes which is our own outfits
we just told on be seen as passive no
big logo you know colorful and stuff
ends so yeah just it just just died yes
do you ever need to wear the same thing
on several shooting days yes you have to
wear the same thing two days in a row
yeah I think it's pretty common
knowledge entertaining for filming it's
just easier what time did you start
filming on average I started filming
about six seven ish early which is hard
I'm not a morning
all to the first few episodes we started
I liked 6:00 a.m. until 9 p.m. because
it was so many of us
dude everyone get along yeah I've got
ones that grew we'll chat on there and I
read a great book so it's been lovely I
think when you go through some things
that intense black with all you get
along and I think you know if we didn't
support each other throughout this
experience things would have been much
more difficult
what do you think you put 10 people in a
sweaty climbing send get them drunk on
Prosecco than that before another one's
gonna get along honey what is bull
Hollywood like of camera this is you
know Paul Holly which is a nice guy I
think you know he has a role to play and
I think he plays it really well I
[Music]
actually don't really talk to them on
camera like oh I have no idea how much
time went by before your showstopper
challenge to when the judges actually
tasted it it was probably about 40
minutes the longest 40 minutes of matter
it's a panda so like the earlier week
there was more time
whereas later me what will you know this
about most before the first tapping was
the most stressful thing was judging I
hated Genting I was most most nervous
about kind of meeting everybody making
sure that you know L got along and of
course we're all worried about not being
the first one to go home and luckily I
wasn't I was probably most nervous about
farting on camera what do they do with
money and food where is never unbeaten
fee so the judges give their feedback
and they know actually if your cake
didn't get completely annihilated by the
crew and the production team then you
know it wasn't very good fake so
hopefully you come back if it's after
your interview and just hope that the
cake has gone on a single chromeless how
is bake-off change your life bake-off
has been the best thing that's ever
happened to me I mean I've done a book
now I write recipes all the time I get
to do what I love
it's just incredible I had a great
career that I loved in 80 but then I
decided to quit my job in December and
now I'm just you know a fully kind of
baked out cook and I'm on the mission to
bring back new French food made easy
so yeah it really changed my life
because now I live from my passion it's
made me take myself much less seriously
it's made me very hard-working
and it's made me a sassy queen do you
still love to bake I think I wouldn't be
doing what I do if I didn't love to bake
what's the question I think after the
bait that's a lot of us are saying how
we're gonna take like two months farts
or something like that and I just I just
took about a week alone thank you so
much for watching today and I'm really
excited for the new season and I hope
that you are excited to my book baking
it's enjoyed about nerves a little bit
this is my new book a flash in the pan
simple stinky stove pot recipe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]